breaking a habit is never easy Lord
knows I've got a few none of them are
healthy but thanks to our sponsor fume I
can now look at that problem in a
different way you see not everything in
a habit is actually wrong so instead of
making drastic uncomfortable changes why
not just remove the bad from the habit
and fume is an Innovative award-winning
flavored air device that does just that
instead of faer fume uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemical fume uses delicious
flavors because instead of encouraging
bad habits fume is here to do good your
fume comes with an adjustable airflow
dial and is designed with movable parts
and magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your habit there's orangey and citrusy
flavors which are quite strong you're
getting that that cake you know we all
put off sing something because it's hard
but switching to fume is easy enjoyable
and fun and fume has served over 150,000
customers with so many success stories
and there's no reason that that can't be
you so head to trif nume.com
[Music]
[Applause]
today on the true Jordie podcast I am
joined by the truest it's true it's damn
true it's Kurt Angle our Olympic hero um
I'm so grateful to have him on the show
thanks for coming on M thanks for having
me on man I've just uh watched your
documentary and I can honestly say it
might be the quickest I've ever cried uh
watching his documentary because it's so
emotional uh from the Geto and it was
fantastic to get a real personal side of
the athlete um and were you like daunted
by putting it out there like everything
the way you
did uh it wasn't easy uh you know having
those emotions come back and uh I will
say this the director Alex Perry did an
incredible job uh he brought the best
out of me and the worst and uh I thought
that uh the documentary was really well
done yeah it was one of the best docu
comies I've ever seen in my life as
someone who watched you from you know
day one in the we but didn't really
fully understand what what was in your
previous life running up to that it was
quite mindblowing and I think one of the
things that really hit me as a fight fan
was wow what an athlete I mean you were
a beast like unbelievable a demon of a
trainer um and I I kind of wondered what
what was your like most natural gift in
your opinion as an athlete my work ethic
uh I I I was a good athlete I wasn't the
best athlete but I was a pretty good
athlete but um it was the work ethic it
was a finding a way to win and my way to
win was to get my opponents tired so the
harder I train the better well
conditioned I got the better chance I
had at getting those guys tired and
beating them so that was the whole idea
in 1995 and 96 during the world
championships in the Olympic uh Olympics
uh Olympic games uh was to where my
opponents down and it worked extremely
well uh I actually almost quit wrestling
in 1994 for good uh because I couldn't
beat these two wrestlers that kept
beating me I couldn't make the world
team and I knew if I couldn't make the
world team I couldn't make the Olympic
team so um I I decided to quit and I
took about five months off and every day
it AE me alive I kept thinking you know
what am you know what if I could have
won I'm never going to find out unless I
see it through to the end and I'm going
to regret it if I don't try so I came
back but I came back with a game plan uh
it was called exhaust training and it's
when you train to your exhausted and
that's when the training actually begins
and and it's almost a form of torture I
learned this from the University of Iowa
head wrestling coach Dan Gable he caught
his wrestlers this and uh when I when I
went through it out there uh I realized
I need to up my game that uh these guys
are the way that I should be trading and
in terms of your cardio like what was
the best work I for you to to to get to
that point well you know what it it
wasn't just a workout um you know I
would condense a bunch of workouts in
the one so uh like when I would start
off in the morning I'd go for a six mile
run I'd have to do it in under 38
minutes that's a six and a half minute
mile so um I I ran it pretty fast when I
got done with that and I would do 2000
meter Hill Sprints up a hill 100 meters
with a guy on my back over my shoulders
I run up there and I jog down run up jog
down and then I would take it over to my
uh apartment where I had an air dime
bike and I would airdine uh on Sprint
for a minute and then go tread lightly
for a minute and do that for a for a
whole hour and then and then I would do
another um probably another 30 hundred
yard wind Sprints uh and then I would
get in a sauna stretch and uh that'd be
my first workout and then you know I
would do three and dur day so the second
workout was my wrestling workout and uh
I trained uh really hard with the the
wrestling workout I I wrestled live for
at least for two and a half hours and uh
and then my third workout was more
strength training um it was uh
Plyometrics and uh and some more
conditioning and so I would train about
10 hours a day every day and I only took
one day off a month and that was it so
my training was filled with a lot of
events you know when you were a young
guy cuz we didn't really get to explore
this in the documentary you're obviously
you're going to have an ego you're
you're a wrestling champion and you're
you're you're doing the things that
young men do you're dating girls you're
you're living the life what was your ego
like what was your personality like as a
younger man well let me tell you this um
I didn't date as many girls as I should
have I didn't go to as many parties I
and and the reason is I sacrificed all
that for something greater and that was
the only Olympic gold medal uh that was
my dream since I was a kid so I didn't
do a lot of stuff growing up I didn't I
didn't go out with my friends I didn't I
didn't go to parties I didn't you know
go to social events I would I spent my
time training and that's that's how I
was ever since I was in high school yeah
and um so I didn't have much of a of a
social life and you know I I didn't mind
that I I didn't care about that I did
have a girlfriend we would hang out at
my house or her house you know when I
wasn't training uh what didn't do a lot
not not a lot grown up so as far as ego
I didn't have an ego I was uh I was very
uh grounded and uh I was very focused on
one thing and that was wrestling it's
very unusual for a young man at your age
at that point to be so disciplined and
dedicated you know when you met your dad
in the documentary it it must have have
been to do with him because he was a
tough guy disciplined himself do you
think he was the main reason for it or
were they other [__] no he was the
main reason that the light bulb went off
of my head I um before before my dad
died I wasn't focused i w you know I
actually wasn't doing that well you know
and the documentary they say I was a
great athlete since when I was born
that's not true I was probably the wor I
was the worst athlete in my family and
that wasn't bad because everybody in my
family were good athletes but I lost a
lot when I was younger I cried a lot I
was a real cry baby my family died if I
ever be good at sports and when my dad
died my freshman year in high school he
he told me this the year before before
he died he said you're gonna be the one
and I I didn't understand him you know
but he knew for some reason that I'd
break out of this crybaby stage and end
up being a great performer and um so I
didn't understand what he meant and when
he passed away the next year I thought
my dad said I'm going to be the one I
got I gotta I got to start working hard
now so I was motivated for him because
he's the one that told me you're going
to be the one that pull us the family
out and and make the name famous and uh
and I did I you know and and my dad was
right but I that's what enabled me to
have the courage to go out there and
train harder than anybody else that
really hit me in the documentary because
I lost my mother probably at a similar
age to when you lost your father and I
had a very similar feeling of I I've got
to do well for you now I've got to prove
you right and seeing you do that was
really emotional and and you know you're
you're an older man yourself now you're
probably older now than your dad was
when he died I would assume same age
right now or around the wow wow so so I
I I can only assume as as I am you may
be sort of um learning who he was from
different eyes as as you're like oh
that's why you did this and you know
you're understanding him a bit
differently now have youever ever and I
hope you don't mind me asking this I do
apologize if it's an intrusive question
but have you ever thought of of of why
your dad um had the alcohol thing
because you mentioned it but I wondered
if now now you thought about that no you
know what I don't know why I don't know
how uh don't know what happened in his
life to make him uh revert alcohol um he
did drink it all day but but for some
strange reason it didn't really affect
him um he showed up my spor events he
showed up to work uh he'd go to church
every week every Sunday and actually
kind of I think the reason why he kind
of went to church is because we would go
to the club afterward he would could go
go drink with his friends you know and
so I I we kind of got in this routine
where my dad you know made sure that we
were first in his life but that liquor
was second and he was gonna you know
when we go to a baseball game and I'd
play we go to the bar afterward my dad
would have a a few drinks and I would
play video games so so uh it was always
intertwined the alcohol was always
intertwined with the sports so it it was
really crazy but my dad um he he W he
was a functional alcoholic he was able
to um to uh you know exist um even
drinking the alcohol now don't get me
wrong when he go to sleep he would chug
you know two big glasses of rum just
chug them back to back and and he would
pass out and then he wake up in the
morning when he go up in the morning he
drank a whole glass of rum before he
went to work and then he would drink
during lunch then he drink after work
and then he would drink a night after
dinner then so on you know the the whole
um the whole pattern continued so it was
seeing that um you know I I we weren't
abused as kids so it it wasn't so bad
but you know I look at it now and I
think I didn't talk much with my father
I I didn't have a a you know
communicated relationship with him and
it's because he was always either
working or sleeping you know or he was
watching our our Sports which means I
was playing while he was sitting there
watching so the only time we get to talk
is in the car on the ride home and uh
that was it then my dad would you know
take his drink and go to sleep uh so it
w it was a really odd relationship but I
knew my Dad loved me because he loved
watching me compete yeah it it really uh
hit me how he was just such a man he
really comes across as an old school guy
who was trying to protect you um as much
as he can and and carry on when you say
functional that takes strength that to
be a functional alcoholic it takes real
strength to do that um and and and to
lose a male role model like him but then
also to end up losing you know your
wrestling role model in Dave Schulz not
long
after um it it hit me when I was
watching that like wow this what this
guy must have been in at that time when
you join Fox catcher which for those who
don't know is a hugely famous wrestling
side where all the best of the best were
training under Dave Schultz and he
particularly took a shine to you and
then this crazy owner of the wrestling
school takes a gun out and and shoot him
I mean what was that like for you going
through that it must have been insane
mate you know it was crazy is I I would
train at Fox catcher probably seven
months a year uh because it was in
Pennsylvania yeah it was right down the
road for me three or 4 hour drive so I
would go there and I'd bounce back and
forth from my hometown to Philadelphia P
where Fox catcher was and um I I you
know it I I uh called Dave the day that
he got killed I called him right around
the time he got shot I left him a
message on his message answer machine
and I told him that I'm coming out the
next day to train with them and uh I go
to practice that night after I made that
call I went to practice in Pittsburgh
down at Kan University it's to college
in the city of Pittsburgh and uh I
wrestled I I I trained and afterward I
looked up at the TV and I see on CNN
Dave Schulz shot and murdered and I was
like what is that my Dave Schultz and I
turned up the volume and it was like oh
my God John de punt just killed Dave
Schultz I mean what you know this is my
coach and uh uh and you know looking
back
you know there are a lot of things we
could have done to prevent that I think
that John was unraveling and we were
trying to keep him at Bay just until
after the Olympics then everybody was
gonna quit afterward you know it was one
of those things where everybody need the
money that they were getting until we TR
until we got to the Olympics and then we
were gonna we were gonna take a hike and
leave Fox catcher uh but we didn't make
it to that point because John deont shot
and killed Dave Schultz before the
Olympics so it it was it was hard for me
because I didn't have an Olympic coach
the last six months of my career uh Dave
was my Olympic coach and uh so I I but
Dave taught me enough to know what I had
to do from here on in and uh I started
training myself and and it worked
because because Dave gave me the
strength the knowledge and the courage
to do that and uh I owe Dave so much to
my career I don't think I W would have
won the Olympic gold medal for war for
Dave Schultz da Dave uh being the size
he was and as you said he threw you
around despite being a smaller you were
a smaller
heavyweight yeah that's a humbling
experience right there yeah he 165
pounds yeah I was
215 damn I mean he he obviously being a
smaller guy would have taught you a lot
of those tricks of the trade that as a
smaller heavyweight you could then
implore against these monster dudes who
you're coming up against because
sometimes the size difference was tough
on you right yeah you know that's Dave
would teach me that's why I was able to
beat these guys uh I couldn't beat them
initially but when Dave started teaching
me the techniques and everything that uh
would help me out um I started beating
those guys you know the guys that were
beating me and uh I owe all that to Dave
and he he would show me little Russian
tie tricks and uh uh a modified Russian
tie and he teach me how to underhook a
guy and you know attack him from an
underhook uh Dave was really good at
that stuff and uh he was the best
technician in the world he actually
learned seven different languages so he
can learn from other countries about
technique from different countries from
Russia from Iran you know so uh he from
Cuba so he he learned all these
different languages so that he could
universally understand wrestling yeah I
mean as a big fan of MMA when you look
at what the dagestani wrestlers have
brought to the table and you can imagine
this guy being the sponge that he was
just plucking from every corner of the
globe in terms of John dupon um what was
your first impressions of him and were
there any noticeable moments that you
can remember when you thought like
you're not right you and I got to keep
my eye on you well it's it's funny but
it's not funny um well John John was a
little odd when I when I first met him
you know he he was quiet he wouldn't say
anything for five minutes then he start
bluring out you know different words and
sentences um he he was
he was always trying to impress
everybody you know he wanted to act like
he knew wrestling so he would tell you
hey To Be A Champion you have to be work
really hard stay dedicated you know he
he told you all the basic stuff you know
and um yeah so one time I was at his
house his Mansion I'm sorry his Mansion
there's a beautiful mansion the
wrestling facility was right next door
to it the farm there are about 40 houses
that all the resters lived in these
houses all over the farm on Fox catching
so I was at John DuPont's mansion and he
um John was um dabbling with drugs at
this particular time uh he was doing a
lot of cocaine and what happened was we
were in his trophy room my a friend of
mine and me and we just ordered pizza
and they were going to bring it to the
trophy room once it got to the mansion
so we were waiting in the trophy room
and John Dupont comes down he has all
this white powder on his nose he's like
hey uh Rob come with me and it's the my
friend that was next to me so Rob goes
with him they go
upstairs comes back down John deont has
a gun his him I was like holy [__] like
what am I gonna do now he has a loaded
gun he's holding it up in the air and
I'm like oh my God I better get out of
here and he says Kurt you need to leave
I was like oh [__] do I leave Rob alone
like I didn't know what to do I was kind
of confused and John de punch said CT
you have to leave right now so he still
had the white Potter in his nose he was
sniffing cocaine so he has his gun as
him and he goes down to the basement of
his Mansion he finds this tunnel it's
from the Civil War uh you know the
DuPont are the ones that made the
gunpowder for the United States uh for
the North and the South to fight each
other okay that's where they got the
name and where they got their money so
he goes downstairs and there's a tunnel
and it's four feet high so you have to
bend over to get get in it and it goes
about 600 yards to another home so it
it's kind of like a safety thing uh
during the war and um so John Dupont
tells Rob to get in first and Rob gets
in he's bent forward so his butts facing
John John gets in and he has a loaded
gun pointed right at Rob's ass and uh he
had to walk like that for 600 yards okay
and John was a little unstable he's high
on cocaine he has a loaded gun in his
hand and they're walking bent over with
a loaded gun pointed at Rob's ass when
Rob told me that I was like oh my God we
we got to do something and uh but things
started to di down and then John started
uh he started accusing me of being in
his walls and accusing other people that
uh they were in his walls he just got
really out of control and it got to the
point that you know Dave was like listen
we have a few more months till the
Olympics let's hunker down let's make it
to that point and then we'll all leave
but it didn't happen because John deont
shortly after that killed Dave Schultz
for you to recover from that and then go
and win the Olympic gold medal but
without the injuries would have been
impressive so to do it with those
physical problems you were battling at
the time is insane and just watching
those matches back and the editing on
that documentary was superb the the
drama it really felt like such a fight
and when you've got this big Iranian
dude and you're doing everything you can
to just get that one little bit of
Advantage from and the thing that really
hit me is the fact that these guys who
are sportsmen are grabbing you by the
neck knowing you've got a broken neck
and yanking it and trying to break it
worse and you're full of painkillers I
mean can you kind of describe what that
is like going through that oh man you
know what um I honestly I couldn't feel
it because I was getting shots at 15
shots of Nova all throughout my neck
five minutes before each one of my
matches so this dumbass that I'm
wrestling he's going for my neck because
he knows it's broken but every time he
reaches for my neck I drop to his legs
and I take him down so the whole the
whole plan his game plan backfired on
him and it made it easier for me to beat
him uh it was fortunate for me but
unfortunate for him but you know he he
did try to hurt my neck he definitely
did he probably did hurt it a little bit
worse uh which is probably why an hour
after my match was over
I was dying my neck was an excruciating
pain I mean I I literally thought that I
was going to die okay it was it hurt
that badly and uh I still had another
match to go during the Olympic trials I
had to wrestle him again and uh I did uh
later on that that day the second match
uh to win the Olympic trials two out of
three matches you have to win two out of
three matches in the finals so I ended
up beating him but man uh he really
tested my neck definitely I felt
speechless watching that when you
finally won that gold medal just to just
to really live that as a as a fan of you
post that to go back and realize I think
if we as wrestling fans that had
understood what you'd gone through I
think the feeling towards you cuz they
were a little bit indifferent when you
first showed up right oh yeah they been
a lot yeah they would have yeah they
well yeah indifferent would have been
good compar yeah they did hate you uh
but you lent into it and and and and
that was a great thing but going back to
the the winning of the gold medal I
watched that post interview when you've
got the gold medal and you're so happy
and you're talking about your dad and
Schult and these I think it was your
grandmother Who You'd lost as well and
you said if I die tonight I'm the
happiest man alive and I just thought
wow if any man can ever say that in any
moment of their life then they've done
good and I I just wondered what it was
like after that like how did you soak it
up or or was there any emptiness when
you finally reached a goal you're like
well what do I do now or what was that
moment like yes yes man I listen all I
thought about when I was a kid growing
up in high school college was the
Olympic gold medal I didn't think about
my life afterward I literally was
focused on the gold medal didn't care
about anything else and after I won the
gold medal I was scared to death I was
like oh my God what am I gonna do now
like I don't I you know I I knew I I had
a college degree I could be a teacher
because I had an education degree
I thought I don't want to be a teacher
really uh so I don't know what I'm going
to do like and I'm not I don't I feel
like I'm not done being an athlete you
know I I felt like that I could do
contribute more uh somehow some way and
the WB approached me in 1996 after the
Olympics and Vince mcgrant offered me a
multi-million dollar deal uh it was an
incredible deal 10year contract multi
million dollar deal and I turned it down
and I'm I'm not sure why I I I know why
because back then amateur wrestling was
competing with pro wrestling so when
people when you'd ask a person on the
street hey what do you do for living I
wrestle oh you're one of those wrestlers
on TV that's the first thing they would
say they wouldn't say oh you one of
those amateur wrestlers trying for the
Olympics and so amateur wrestling kind
of got bitter toward pro wrestling
because they were taking the back seat
because anytime anybody talked about
wrestling people immediately thought Pro
wrest wrestling so I was always taught
stay away from pro wrestling they're
fake you're real you're the real deal
stay away from it and I did and I did
all the way up until 1996 and then when
when Vince McMahon offered me a contract
I went out and met with him and I turned
it down but you know a couple years
later I called him back because I
seriously was not done being an athlete
my neck healed from the Olympics I was
like you know what I started watching
Raw uh in 1998 and I fell in love with
Stone Cold St Austin and I thought man
these guys are great athletes and it's
hilarious I'd love to do something like
this so I called vce mmah and I asked if
that contract still stood he said no but
you can come up and try out I figured uh
nothing in my life's ever come easily
this won't come easy either so I went up
and tried out and after the first day I
picked up on everything so quickly they
offered me a contract but it was only a
$75,000 a year contract and you have to
remember in wrestling pro wrestling you
me I have to pay not for my airfare they
pay for that I have to pay for my hotel
my rental car my food my gas and my
tolls
$75,000 doing 300 shows a year is not
going to cut it okay especially if you
have a family so you know I started out
very humbly uh just like I did in
amateur wrestling which was no no no you
know no secret to me I you know I I've
always been uh started out in humble
beginnings and so I ended up uh signing
with the WWE and within seven months I I
was on TV and uh within the 10 months of
my rookie year I won the World
Championship so I literally became a
millionaire my first year wrestling and
with a $75,000 guarantee I made a
million dollars more than that uh over
the year so um I knew right then and
there that I'm in the right place and uh
you know this is gonna this is going to
be my payoff for the Olympics for
everything I did to work so hard because
amateur wrestling there's no money in it
unfortunately there's not I mean there
is if you want to coach and you want to
put on clinics and stuff like that but
for the most part there's not a lot of
money in it so here here was my payoff
and so I went to the WWE and I fell in
love with that just like I did amateur
wrestling it felt watching it back that
if the UFC had have been what it is
today that you would have automatically
you'd have been a UFC champion I don't
know if he'd been Champion but I I
definitely would have join the UFC I
would have signed with them they they
contacted me in 1996 uh right after the
Olympics as well and back then you know
Dana White wasn't any part of it uh they
they I think the the the Gracies owned
it they offered me a 10f flight deal for
150 Grand that's 15,000 a fight that
didn't sound like a lot of money to me
back then it was for the UFC because
those guys were only getting five grand
you know for a fight or you know if they
won the whole tournament they got 50,000
I was that so um you know the contract
wasn't so bad from the UFC standpoint
back then but what it is now today I
mean these guys are getting 16 18
million a fight on pay-per-view now you
know Conor McGregor and Brock Lesnar and
Ronda Rousey so um I passed on it and uh
I started wrestling in 1998 with WWE and
by 2000 uh UFC started becoming
mainstream and I was like man I'd love
to do that and uh and then what happened
was literally a half a year later I
broke my neck again and that was it I
when I broke my neck again I lost all my
strength in my arms uh lost feeling in
my hands uh and till this day I have no
feeling in my two pinky fingers and my
pointer Fingers um so I I have a lot of
neck damage and and and it caused me to
lose a lot of strength in my upper body
so there was no way even though I
entertained it in 2006 I went to Dana
White 2006 and I said hey I'm ready he's
like okay this is what we're going to do
and he he he offered me a deal he wanted
me to be on the real fighter with Kimbo
Slice um I don't know if you uh oh wow I
remember that Series yeah Ultimate
Fighter with Kimbo Slice and I said Dana
those guys don't get paid to be on that
show he said don't worry I'll pay you a
substantial amount of money just to be
hon it I'll take care of you but he said
listen whether you win or not I'll give
you a sixf flight deal I said 'well that
sounds fair so I was getting ready to do
it and I ended up signing with Impact
Wrestling TNA uh a week prior and I
thought they I thought that I could do
both which was crazy it was stupid but I
was you know TNA was gonna give me a
part-time contract so I figured I could
train UFC as well so I told Dana I just
signed with TNA C can I do both he said
no you can't do both I said well Dana I
have to respect this contract I have
with TNA I'll come back to you if if my
contract expires in a decent amount of
time and I'm still at at an age that you
want me I'll come back to you so uh I
had to pass on UFC because they wouldn't
allow me to do both and I just signed
with TNA and I didn't want to tell TNA
listen I'm not coming I'm gonna go with
the UFC because I just signed the deal
so yeah respect for that and you
mentioned Vince mcmah obviously one of
the biggest players in in sports
entertainment history and you've known
him from you know the guy in the
attitude dud era who you know the kiss
my ass club and all the funny stuff he
was doing to all the way now where he is
This Global icon who's now doing deals
with the UFC in Saudi Arabia and how has
your opinion and uh view of him changed
in this 20 year period or whatever it is
now you know what from the be first day
I met him uh till today even though even
when we weren't talking even when um you
know uh things weren't going so well for
me and I felt like he could have done
more for me I always looked at him as a
father figure and I think it's because
you know I lost Dave Schultz I lost my
dad anybody that that that controlled my
life like my dad controlled my my sports
when I was growing up uh Dave controlled
my wrestling Vince controlled my pro
wrestling I looked up to him as a father
figure and I respected Vince I loved
them and uh so I I I still feel that way
to this day um he he he gave me an
opportunity and I took it now did I
deserve that opportunity you're damn
right I did but but he gave it to me and
I was very grateful for that yeah and
your character when you enter the we it
really jumped off of the page this sort
of innocence and sort of naivity mixed
with arrogance and over over it was a
genius character and I kind of wondered
was that your idea or was the creative
involved like how did that come about
you know what I think they looked at my
personality because I am a little bit
you know naive and a little bit kind of
wonderand off you know I have some add
you know I'm just a really o odd person
but um uh Brian gwartz the writer for
WWE and Vin McMahon they saw me the
person I was and they came up with this
character that they wanted me to be a
milk drinking nerd that claimed that he
had the three eyes intensity Integrity
intelligence but I really didn't have it
because I would cheat to win and even
though I would if someone cheated and
beat me I'd accuse him of it but when I
won and I cheated it didn't matter like
it I didn't cheat so it was a really
really cool um clever character that
they came up with and I was able to
portray it perfectly because they they
took it from part of my personality so
it wasn't that hard for me to do now I'm
not going to lie to you they never
taught me how to cut a promo they didn't
have NXT back then uh they had uh Dory
Funk and Dojo where we had a camp where
we'd go up five days a month up to uh
WWE headquarters and trained there and
very very little promo skills I
literally made it cut one promo and that
was it um so I didn't really learn how
to do that stuff so here Vince my first
night on the air I'm making my debut in
my hometown of Pittsburgh and Vince says
listen this is what you're gonna say
tonight and I looked at him I said
you're not GNA write it down you're not
going to give me like a piece of paper
he said no I'm GNA tell you it and then
you're gonna say it I was like holy [__]
so I'm waiting and he says all right
this is what you're going to say he
starts blurting off these words and I'm
not listening because it's so long okay
I'm like wow this is like three minutes
long four minutes long five minutes long
holy [__] how much is he gonna say and
he gets done talking he goes you now can
you go out and say that and I said Vince
um I didn't hear a word you said you're
gonna have to say it
again so he said listen I'm gonna tell
you one more time you go out there you
say it you swim or if you don't say it
you don't you don't you don't do it
right you fail you sink so it's up to
you you want to survive you go out there
it's it's totally up to you so how how
you do this promo right now is how I'm
going to treat you the rest of your
career and I was like holy crap so I
went out there and cut the promo and I
got about 80% of it right and Vince was
like this kid has something because he
he he remembered 80% of what I had what
I told him to say and it was a five
minute promo so uh then he started um
you know they they literally I started
training for only seven months before I
went on WWE television so I literally
didn't know what I was doing in the ring
I didn't I didn't understand psychology
yet I knew how to do the moves and
everything and the bumping and the
selling but I didn't know how to do the
psychology you know good guy versus bad
guy good guy out wrestles the bad guy
the bad guy cuts down the good guy gets
heat on him beats him up then the good
guy makes a comeback the bad guy uh
tries to cheat to win the good guy
overcomes and wins the match you know
that's psychology so while I'm on the
job I'm on TV I'm learning this every
week because every wrestler I'm
wrestling is talking to me in the ring
every single night they're leading me
through the match so I did that for
about a year and because I I I was such
a good follower I became a good leader I
started leading the matches so it really
helped me but learning on the job was
tough because if you if you fail you
fail they're going to fire you but if
you rise to the occasion they're going
to keep you and they're going to make
you a huge Superstar so there was a lot
of pressure on me and in terms of those
guys who would lead the Dan who uh in
particular did you feel like you learned
the most out from they have me starting
with like guys like um um Bob Holly
Steve Blackman Venus uh Eddie Guerrero
Chris Chris Jericho so Chris W I was in
really good hands like there were a lot
of guys that were really teaching me the
ropes of wrestling and uh you know then
I was mixing in they were mixing in I
you know I I wrestled The Rock within
two months when I was on TV like they
literally threw me in the main event
like two months later and uh so I was
wrestling Undertaker Rock Triple H stun
cold C Boston and that's when I really
started learning how to wrestle in the
main event and uh those guys taught me a
lot him uh k as well uh you name it the
guys that I wrestled they they they were
incredible so I I owe a lot of credit to
those guys and you've just mentioned
Eddie Guerrero and Chris benoa which is
um two um you know huge wrestlers in
that time period who obviously had very
sad ends to their lives and you from
what I've seen on social media um some
people kind of you know shy away from
talking about Chris banir and kind of
act like it didn't he didn't really
exist and you've been very sort of open
and and not hid it um and I wondered
sort of what the logic was behind that
and how how you feel about you know the
Legacy um that you have with these guys
and sharing the ring and also just back
in that time period when the when those
guys passed away what that was like to
experience okay well Eddie and Chris
they became Legends when they became
World Championships in WWE I mean they
were The Underdogs both of them are five
eight both of them weigh about 180 190
pounds very undersized and here they are
the same year at the same time they win
the World Championships and they're best
friends as well so uh it was all it all
came together for them but I I will tell
you the reason why I keep Chris beno's
Legacy going is because I have my best
matches with him if I pretend like he
didn't exist I pretend that I didn't
exist because my greatest match is 2003
Royal Rumble against Chris benois for
the WWE Championship uh Iron Man match
against Chris benois uh we had we had
WrestleMania 17 match against Chris
benois you named it um black backlash
pay-per-view against benois I had my
best matches with Beno and if I don't
recognize Chris benois I'm not recog
recognizing myself because they were
literally my best matches now I'm not
going to lie to you I had some great
matches with Shawn Michaels and Brock
leser and Undertaker Rock and Triple H
and Stone Cold uh but um you know for me
Beno was the guy because he reminded me
of me uh when he got in there he was an
intense technical master that knew
everything about wrestling and uh him
and I meshed really well in the ring and
I I I was always excited to wrestle him
but I always knew it was gonna be hard
because he matched my intensity he was
able to uh uh step it up a level stay
with me and no other wrestler has been
able to do that yeah I I've heard many
stories about um the the length span
where would go to teach these young cats
in the in the wrestling locker room you
know if you disrespect people he'll make
you do a thousand squats right there and
then guy was a a tough guy and and
obviously you know no one seen coming
what what would eventually transpire but
I I was wondering if you felt like um I
don't know if there was moments where
you noticed he was in a in a decline
mentally prior to what
happened ah man you know what Chris was
Chris was unique uh he was very quiet to
begin with um he didn't say a lot um he
he he spoke a lot with his wrestling but
he you know they they never asked him to
do a lot of promos because he didn't
really enjoy talking that much and Chris
was a very quiet individual so it was
really hard to read him you didn't know
if he was having a good day or a bad day
because he was always Chris benoa I mean
most of the time he would he had a you
know he was emotionless you know you
didn't see any emotion in his face he
you know he just had that poker face and
uh so you never thought what how Chris
benwell what he was thinking or what was
going on in his mind and I don't know if
it had to do with brain damage or
whatever it was uh nobody will will ever
know to be honest with you but um it's
it's a shame what happened but I am
really ultimately surprised that it was
Chris benoir that did that I hear you I
hear you and I appreciate you opening up
about that and you know when it comes to
technical wrestling you are right there
at the very top with people like Chris
benoir and I actually think like looking
back at it now when you look at your
legacy I felt like you were clip sprad
hot you know you you had a bit more to
your game than him your personality was
more Dynamic do you feel like you're um
you are that number one technical
Savage um you know I'm up there there's
no doubt about it
um you know I brought a lot of my
amateur wrestling to the table uh you
know a lot of guys they do the pro
wrestling stuff but um I was able to
intertwine both and I think that's what
made me special and and you were high
flying as well you did that moon off the
cage it was crazy yeah every once in a
while I pull that out of my hat but um
yeah you know what I I thought that I
thought I was at the time I was
wrestling I thought I was the best
wrestler in the world um uh will I say
was I the Great of all time no because
uh to be the greatest of all time I
think you need to put in 20 uh uh
consecutive years with one company and I
didn't do that I put six and a half with
WWE then 11 with TNA and then another
two with WWE so um I never was able to
stay with one company for a 20-year
period so uh unfortunately I can't put
myself up there as one of the greatest
of all time uh although I think my
technique does speak for itself and at
the time uh I think my favorite wrestler
was Brock Lesnar and you and him had
such a great rivalry and those jokey
moments backstage where you were like
pushing and shoving each other and you
know that rivalry it was so fun to watch
but also there was a hint of reality
there like you were both true wrestlers
true beasts and what was it like locking
up with him uh and having that time
together well we we had a connection
right away um because we were both
amateur wrestlers and we both stod uh
each other and and what we accomplished
throughout our lives so we we were
literally traveling Partners even though
we were having programs against each
other you're not supposed to drive with
the person that you're having a program
with but we did it anyway uh sorry Vince
but um Brock was special because not
only was he a great amateur wrestler but
this guy was the most powerful uh
quickest person I've ever met for
size um strongest uh
smartest um just overall best wrestler
I've ever seen like when when I tell you
that Brock would have been good at
whatever he wanted to do I'll give you
an example um he wrestled in college won
national title then he went to WWE
became WWE Champion and he said you know
what I'm gonna go to pro football and he
would have made it in pro football if he
they told him they wanted him to go to
NFL Europe for a year when NFL Europe
existed did uh but he was the last cut
for the Vikings he was that close and he
never played a day of football in his
life that shows how incredible of an
athlete he is and not that they need to
wins the UFC title and he's like you
know what I'll go back to WWE and win
another world title so it didn't matter
where he Brock went he was gonna succeed
no matter what it didn't matter what
sport you put him in basketball you put
him in football you put him in you know
soccer doesn't matter he's going to
excel he's going to be at the top he's
going to be the best at whatever he does
that's how good Brock lesler is I guess
you must have been the least person
surprised when he achieved the UFC
heavyweight title no you know what I saw
his first fight when he Tapped Out the
Frank Mir and I knew right then the way
he manhandle Frank Mir he just didn't
have the knowledge you know Frank got
him with a leg lock and you know an
ankle lock a foot lock and um and you
know Brock didn't understand you know
how he was able to do that and you know
Brock didn't really know how to defend
that once he did he was good to go so uh
I knew right then I was like wow he
manhandle Frank M this guy's going to be
a force to be reckoned with and he was I
mean he won next fight he had he won the
world he won the UFC title and then he
defended it I think for three or four
fights before he lost it yeah I felt
like that added some quite a lot of
legitimacy to to you guys um and proving
that you know a lot of these big time
wrestlers actually have badass
attributes and can actually get they do
it and in terms of Brock's match with
you at WrestleMania the summer assault
moon salt I think it was that went wrong
you're in the ring with him you're also
badly injured prior to this you had a
broken neck before you went in there
he's now down I mean you two really went
to hell him back together what was that
experience like were you worried about
his health in the ring that time be
honest with you I wasn't worried about
his health at all until he hit that
shooting star press when he landed on
his head I was like oh [__] he broke his
neck too I literally I thought you know
he was knocked out he got a concussion
uh he sprained his neck he didn't he
didn't injure it too badly but the way
he landed he could have been paralyzed
thank God he has a 22inch neck because
that that's what protected him and uh
when that happened I I froze I was like
oh no what do I do I I need to get my
surgery tomorrow so if I cover and pin
him I'm G to have to hold a title
another day and I was like I don't want
to do that so what do I do you know and
so I was in a situation where uh I
didn't really know what to do and the
referee said cover him I'm like I don't
want to cover him he's like cover him
because he you know you gotta make it
look like it's gonna be a false finish
so I covered him and I said Brock kick
out Brock kick out Brock kick out and he
kicks out I like oh thank God at least
he's coherent you know he he know he
knows what's going on around him so I
said Brock I we were both on our backs
and I I looked over at him I said Brock
uh can you get up he said I think so I
said do you think you'd give me an F5 he
said yeah I think so so I I got up and I
went to pick him up and he cut me off
booted me in the gut picked me up gave
me the F5 in the finish and that was it
it shows what a badass Brock leser is
because he literally could have just
laid there and just you know we could
have did a double count and ended up
with a draw uh but but Brock finished
the match and that's the kind of
individual he is obviously you with your
injuries with uh the neck issue that you
had consistently there was some of those
times where I I've seen one clip of
Brock himself smashing you into the
turnbuckle and your neck just sort of
cranking to the side looks so painful
and look you're you're putting your body
in the hands of other people and
sometimes the mistakes are getting made
have you ever yourself or seeing other
people like have real problems with each
other after the match because they
didn't look after each other and there's
an injury there or um you know what
there there was one time when I got to
fight with Eddie
Guerrero and H what happened was We were
supposed to go out and get heat on Edy
he had a tag match and he got done with
the tag match and myself and the Honor
Society this was my group that I had at
that particular time I think it was uh
Luther Reigns and uh Mark gindra and we
went out there we got heat on Eddie we
beat him up I didn't touch Eddie I
actually worked on Chavo Guerrero and
they they beat up Eddie pretty badly so
we went back to the uh gorilla where you
wait be you know when you when you leave
the arena you go back to the gorilla
where Vince McMahon is and they're
watching the show and I went back there
and Edie comes back and he's flipping
out he's going crazy who the what the
effort you guys punching me and hitting
me and you're not taking care of me and
I said Eddie I didn't do it he said you
did do it I said I didn't do it Eddie he
pushed me and I push pushed him back and
he shoots a double leg on me I was like
oh that was a
mistake so I SC and got him in a front
faceold and I started choking him out
and I got him choked out and and you
know what's crazy is um that should have
never happened I mean I it it was partly
my fault I should have just taken the
blame and said Eddie you're right my
guys were tough on you I was tough on
you because they were my boys and
instead I I I I showed a lot of pride
and and uh I didn't want him to think
that I was responsible for the guys that
that beat him up but um you know Eddie
uh probably a half hour later uh someone
says hey why would you shoot a a double
EG on Kurt Angle he said because I'm
[__]
stupid so became a joke in the locker
room but yeah that's the only time I saw
that but you know what I'll tell you
this Brock broke my neck when you know
you talk about that that turnbuckle spot
where I my neck went sideways that was
the that was the SEC first time I broke
my neck was the Olympics second time the
first time in WWE was when Brock did
that to me and then six months later
after I healed I came back Brock hit me
over the head with a chair straight
overhead you know usually you swing
sideways so it doesn't condense your
neck he went straight over as far as he
could and I I broke four vertebrae and
uh I was out again I had to have surgery
again it was horrible
so I had a horrible run for two and a
half years between 2003 and 2006 where I
broke my neck four different occasions
that really was something and going back
to Eddie um it kind of adds to the
legend of Eddie Guerrero not being the
biggest guy I mean you know you you're
shooting a double leg on Kurt Angle
what's next swinging for Mike Tyson like
you know
exactly like it's literally the worst
person to shoot a double leg on in the
history of mankind but okay fair play to
him man what a guy
well he did wrest in
high yeah I mean fair play the Latino
Heat wasn't just a gimmick um and um and
your and your broken your broken neck um
it almost um it becomes such a a part of
your life story because of the setbacks
and constantly having to get over that
and um obviously that led to uh you
taking the pain kill painkillers and the
amount of painkillers that you were
taking
it you you being the man you are it kind
of shows what what level you needed to
go to in order to get that relief from
the level of pain I think it was 65 vied
in a day yeah U yeah I'm not proud of it
it blew my
mind well I'll tell you this uh this is
the something that the doctors don't
tell you uh when I broke my neck the
second time the first time in WWE I met
a doctor and he introduced me to
painkillers he said these things are the
greatest things in the world you're
going to love them so I started taking
one every 4 to six hours and uh [__]
after a while your body builds a
tolerance and one doesn't cut it then
you take two then two leads to four four
leads to eight before I knew it I was
taking 65 extra straight Viking a day
this was within a six-month period of
time and I mean we're talking like
almost enough to kill a horse it was
that bad and what happened was my focus
was not wrestling anymore my focus was
where am I going to get the drug next
because I became a drugie I be became an
addict right away uh 65 extra ST I get a
day uh and the reason why I was taking
them was not because of the pain anymore
it's because I was going through
withdrawal so you know if I took 15
painkillers uh few hours later they
would wear off and I start having
withdrawal again I have to take more so
I was taking more all day more and more
all day long every single day
and uh what I realized is uh I um I I
couldn't I I was literally uh there was
a point in time where I I wrestled um uh
Chris or who was it uh Brock Lester we
had a one hour Iron Man match on TV and
uh th this is this is a sad point in my
my life uh we were wrestling a one hour
Iron Man match and the night before we
were at a house show and um I just got
done wrestling and uh my brother calls
me and says he listen your sister died
of a heroin
overdose I was like what he said yeah
she she just died uh you need to come
back home and and plan the funeral and
and uh get this moving so you know I was
devastated and I remember going back to
my hotel room and I was crushed I was in
such pain thinking about my sister who
was only 40 years old that died and I
took 20 painkillers I had had him in my
hand and I threw him in my mouth and
chewed him up and swallowed them and I
didn't wake up till 3:00 in the
afternoon the next day okay I'm supposed
to have this one hour Iron Man match
with Brock leser and I'm late already to
getting there and uh so the Ws call me
all day because they want to tell me I
don't have to show up that I could go
home and plan a funeral for my sister
that it's okay I don't have to do the
match and I remember saying something to
my sister I said Le what do I do
and she said do it for me that's all I
heard and I thought all right I'm I'm
going to do it for her you know what it
was the that one hour with Brock was the
best hour of my life because I didn't
have to think about Leanne at that
particular time I was focused on the
match because of my sister because I was
doing it for her but for that one hour I
didn't have to think about what happened
to her and it was like my release and I
was like man I'd love to go two hours
and not have to think about my sister or
three or four I'll go all day long I'll
go 24/7 like that's that was my
mentality just to to get away from my
you know from thinking about my sister
and the only thing that would get me
there was the painkillers so I was
taking more and more and more and and
all I was doing is trying to hide the
pain physically and emotionally and it
it got out of control and I'll give you
an example what I was doing I had 12
different doctors that were giving me 12
different script
of medication and I had to set up a a
calendar because you couldn't go to the
same Pharmacy so you had to have 12
different doctors go to 12 different
pharmacies so I had all these different
pharmacies on my calendar and then it
still wasn't enough so I had to buy 500
of them illegally from Mexico so I was I
was
buying uh 2,000 painkillers a month just
to keep my my my addiction
going how much do you think you were
spending on that that
$7,000 a month wow but remember I was
making a lot of money so the money
wasn't really yeah yeah an issue it's
worth it at that point in your mind and
and the the the bit the bit around your
sister in the documentary it was another
real choking point for me because I felt
like I I remember watching The Iron Man
match not having a clue what you were
going through so to know that now
understanding I'm a totally different
angle as an adult myself who's been
through hell myself it was a really
unbelievable moment and you talked about
how you tried so hard with your sister
to help her in every way you could and
and like many people do you you try
everything but but no one can save them
but them and that is the the saddest bit
about it you can only do what you can do
and I just wondered because it did seem
to hurt you a lot had you forgiven
yourself and not being able to save her
when when obviously no one
can yeah you know what I I have and it
was hard for me to do but I look back
and and I
realized I I didn't have a choice my
sister kind of put me in that situation
uh she wasn't GNA stop she was lying to
me I continued to to Aid her drug
addiction even though I thought I was
paying for her bills um so it was one of
those things where I gave her one last
warning and I said listen uh you know
you can't do this same anymore you you
know you got to stay clean and and uh
you know stop using my money for for uh
drugs and um and she continued to and it
it was really sad because she she moved
up here I made her move up here to
Pittsburgh and she relapsed again and
that's when I decid not to talk to her
anymore I said listen I'm not going to
talk to you till you get your life
straight because I've done too much for
you and I've worked too hard and I've
stressed out way way too much I don't
want any part of this until you get
better and that's when she died and
that's why I felt so guilty and it's
hard on me till this day but I know that
I had to give her an ultimatum I had
to yeah I mean you were given your own
ultimatum later in life and and you
chose the good path thank god um but but
before you got there we see um footage
of of Mark Henry talking about how he
was looking at you going you can't be
acting like this your c angle you're a
hero you've got to set an example for
people and stone called Steve Austin
saying how you were on the phone him
slurring your words and now obviously as
a sober man what was it like seeing your
friends go into detail like that and how
hard it was for them oh you know what I
can't imagine how uncomfortable I made
them um I didn't know I was slurring I
didn't know that uh when you're when
you're caught up in the drugs you don't
realize that you're supposed to be a
role model and you're supposed to be you
know people are looking at at you I
didn't realize people were really
looking up to me and looking at me as a
role model and you know seeing my every
move and you know when you're in the
when you're in the public eye you can't
do anything you know you have to make
sure you stay clean and and stay out of
trouble and uh what I realized is I I
was so careless taking the pills and
passing out in public and I mean I
didn't know I was doing this stuff when
Stone Cold Steve Austin said that
um I was like whoa I didn't know that
you know when Mark H Henry said yeah you
were supposed to be a role model you
don't do that stuff I was like man he's
right and and I started by like I
started getting down on myself like man
you let you let a lot of people down and
you made stone cach Steve Austin feel
uncomfortable because he called you and
you were talking to him and you were
slurring and he doesn't want to be
around that and I put him in a position
to feel uncomfortable because I want to
take my drugs and I I think that you
know hearing those words from them
really put a explanation point on the
reason why I got sober there was the the
chat with Vince where he kind of um put
it on you that you need to get help I I
wondered what that was like but also if
there was anyone else any of the other
wrestlers who may have said anything
around that time you know what I don't
remember H honestly I'm sure some of
them did but I remember Vince because
you know I was there I was meeting with
him and uh you know he wanted me to get
help and I didn't want help and that's
why I left the company and I ended up
going to TNA Impact Wrestling and what's
crazy is I ended up doing what Vince
wanted me to do I quit my painkillers
but I was still taking this dose of
morphine my doctor put me on a two doses
of little tiny pill morphine pills and
that would keep me from getting withd
draw so I wouldn't have to take all
these painkillers I just take these two
tiny morphine P pills twice a day and uh
but then I started drinking alcohol
excessively because everybody in TNA was
drinking so I was like I'll drink too so
I started drinking and it became a habit
a bad habit I would literally drink 12
uh cans of beer after my show at night
and pass out I did this for about a year
or so and after that I started getting
careless and Reckless and out of control
and irresponsible I was literally going
to the the the alcohol store The Beer
Store grabbing the beer and drinking it
while driving to the next town where I I
was gonna have the next show and what
that got me was four DUIs in five years
I lost my reputation everything I worked
for I was at lowest point in my life I
called my wife from jail after my fourth
DUI and my wife said I can't do this
anymore you either go to rehab or I'm
taking the kids and I'm leaving and I
thought wow I I don't want to lose my
wife my kids not over drugs not over Al
alcohol so I ended up going to rehab you
know what I went I went to rehab I
didn't go to get better I go I went just
so my wife wouldn't leave me and when I
got in there I realized yeah I realized
I had a disease I mean it was bad they
scare the hell out of you in there they
make you feel like when you get out if
you [__] up you're a [__] up you know
that that's really the the message they
send you you know you get out of you get
out of rehab and you re you relapse
you're a screw up you know you're you're
you're an addic you're you're you're an
addict you're an addict regardless
whether you go whether you re um whether
you uh do it again or not you know
you're I'm always gonna be an addict I
know that but uh you can control that
and uh I was able to uh you know I've
been able to stay clean for 12 years now
13 years actually it's so strange to me
how people can reach such physical
Heights and achievements like you did
Olympic gold wrestler and and many other
athletes out there boxing world
champions and then at a point in their
life that that addiction that made them
great can also be their their downfall
that addictive side of their personality
where they just think they're Superman
um and and for me the there was two
heroes in the documentary one was you at
the start and one was your wife what a
woman what a woman I've got to say good
God you picked the right one mate cuz
she absolutely I you could see she did
want to say those things to you she
didn't want to put you under the
pressure but she had to do that to be
the only one to hold a fire under you
and go if you don't do this this is the
consequences well you know what I put
her through a lot of pain there a lot of
nights I would get all messed up and I
wouldn't be there for her or the kids
and she dealt with it and the best way
she could and you know she would bring
it up here and there and uh you know I
would just tell her hey don't don't
worry I'm I'll be fine I'll I won't
drink tonight and I'd end up drinking
you know it just I I was always lying to
her and that's what an addict does he
never tells the truth he always lies and
uh my wife uh was so strong for me when
I couldn't be strong for myself and she
kept the family together and you know to
this day I owe her my life I owe her
everything because she was able to keep
the family together while I was being a
screw up and uh that means more to me
than anything thing that shows her
loyalty lies with me and that means so
much to me yeah there's a lot of people
who think love is telling the other
person everything they want to hear but
sometimes it's telling them what they
need to hear right and she the strength
that she had was fantastic um so that
was a real another emotional moment in
the the documentary there and you
mentioned being in jail that that must
have been such a weird moment for
someone who is who was revered by so
many people as a hero
and now you're feeling like you know the
lowest of the
law what was it like just in that
moment I I didn't feel like I was
letting myself down I felt like I was
letting my fans down and my family down
and uh that that's harder on me than
than being uh you know blaming myself or
or uh you know I I I I felt like you
know I I I did them wrong and uh because
not strong enough to stay clean that I'm
a weak individual and uh that that's
what really uh opened my eyes is I'm not
a weak person why am I doing this and
you know when I was in rehab I kept
thinking when I get out I'm gonna [__]
up I know I am like I was literally um I
was psyching myself out because you know
they're telling us in there if you
relapse and you will and it's like okay
what why you telling me I'm going to
relapse I'm trying to stay clean you
know they're like well if when you
relapse and you will get back on the
wagon and keep going you know so it's
like man am I gonna get through this
because most addicts don't most addicts
go back to it once they get out am I
gonna be one of the fuckups and uh
fortunately because of that me being
aware of myself all the time of me not
wanting to be a [__] that actually
helps me stay clean and talking about it
with you and me right now talking about
it and and what I went through and
everything telling our stories helps me
to stay clean that's why I give speeches
to individuals uh uh that I um I go to
different companies and I give speeches
about my addiction and my recovery and
uh that that's something that really
helps me with my recovery yeah I did
wonder how when when you compare the
things you've had to go through in life
how did winning a gold medal in the
Olympics compared to trying to get sober
again like in terms of effort and
challenges and one is mental and
physical U that's the Olympics uh the
the the the um addiction part it starts
out physical but then it's just
completely mental and uh so you have to
remember what are the first physical
signs like what how did the physical bit
hit you at the start the withdrawal
listen when you go on rehab you're off
the painkillers and off the morphine off
alcohol uh after a day you start going
through a drw and you're sweating you're
going to the bathroom you're pissing
yourself you're crapping yourself uh you
you have a headache you you feel like
you don't have any bones inside you uh
you're hot but you're cold it's it's the
worst feeling in the world and it lasted
me for about a week which means I was
taking a lot of [__] uh because usually
it only takes people three to five days
took me a whole seven days to get clean
to get uh through uh withdrawal so uh it
was a lot longer for me and the thing is
what makes me want to stay clean today
is knowing what that felt like I don't
want to ever go through that again that
was the worst feeling I've ever been
through worse than my exhaust training
worse than anything I've ever done in my
life going through withdraw is the worst
experience I've ever felt and I don't
ever want to feel it again thank God you
did you did overcome it because we got
to see you sort of come full circle and
have your Hall of Fame moment which is
very well deserved and dedicated to your
wife what was that like for that moment
to just finally to go like I did it you
know like and how that move yeah you
know what it was a great feeling that
WWE brought me back and inducted me into
Hall of Fame and you know for
me you know my my wife giovana wasn't
any part of my WWE career but she was so
supportive of me in my TNA career and
she understood that I had a life before
her
and uh for her to take the back seat and
say hey This Moment's yours go ahead and
do this I felt like when I was up there
I had to mention her and say you know
this is the most important person in my
life because she was there for me at my
worst and she's there for me at my best
and she's letting me do this what I did
in the past that she was no part of you
know uh getting inducted to WB Hall Fame
my wife didn't never saw me wrestl the
WB back in 2006 2005 she did when I came
back in
2017 but she wasn't a part of my life
back then but she she allowed me to
relive that you actually uh adopted
another child yeah that I thought that
was really interesting because you know
you don't see a lot of people do that
when they've already got children and I
just wondered what made you want to do
that together uh well my wife and I we
ended up I have two kids to another
marriage uh Cody and Kira and my wife
and I we end up having three girls right
in a row and uh we were gonna plan on a
fourth we decided you know what it's not
a good decision we're gonna end up
probably with another girl and we won a
boy so we might as well adopt so that's
when we decided to adopt and we ended up
getting a kid um my wife fell in love
with this kid he was 12 years old uh
from
Bulgaria um Just a Nobody you know just
a little skinny malnutrition kid and um
she she fell in love with him and we we
had to go through the process and I got
to tell you it's a long process when you
have DUIs you're trying to adopt oh my
God uh like the process took like three
years was horrible and um lot of lot of
tap to you know break through so uh we
finally got there so we got him when he
was 15 and we got him during the right
before the pandemic and listen to this
if we wouldn't to got him before the
pandemic uh his birthday would have
occurred and uh after the pandemic if we
had to pick him up he would have been 16
and you're not allowed to adopt a
16-year-old they send them on the street
they give him $500 and say you're on
your own go live your life so if we if
the borders the borders got shut down
after we picked them up but if they
would if we would have picked them up be
after the pandemic we would have never
gotten and this poor kid would have
would have never had a life and uh you
know he's doing well right now he's 19
years old uh he's into weightlifting
he's going to be a firefighter um he
joined the wrestling team last year he
did extremely well uh very proud of the
kid so uh yeah we do have a boy his
name's Joseph his Bulgarian name was ion
but uh he wanted to change his name to
Joseph because of his grandfather my
wife's dad so he wanted to be named
after him it's a very nice story and I
think it speaks volumes about the way
your family is and how um again coming
back to the the family unit you know how
important that's been for you guys I was
wondering now that you aren't that
superum guy and you are getting older
and um how is that feeling for you um as
you're getting wiser you know you're no
longer that super athlete are you able
to just accept that or because you know
some guys they have that midlife crisis
thing going on so how are you dealing
with that oh I had it I had it um I'd
say for about a year after I retired um
I I didn't go out the way I wanted to
um I was not in the the best of shape
when I went out uh I was slowing down uh
the reason why I retired is because I I
noticed that my I wasn't half the
wrestler I was and I don't want fans to
remember me as this broken down you know
aging wrestler so that's why I retired
but um you know I didn't get to go out
the way I wanted to so that that that
was really difficult on me so um I did
go through a little bit of a crisis for
about a year and uh I I finally got
through it and I thought it just took me
some time I I thought you know what you
accomplished a lot you should be proud
of yourself um you know I'm at the point
in my life where anything I do now is
icing on top of the cake because there's
really nothing else I need to accomplish
than to prove to myself of of what a
fighter and a champion I was uh
especially overcoming my addiction uh
that's what I'm most proud of and uh so
you know what I do now is I I dabble in
movies I got a movie coming up in
January I just did a movie last March um
I I do some of that um I got a movie uh
uh we're doing about my life story um
which uh we're gonna be start filming
probably next year uh it should be a
pretty cool thing I'll be able to help
out with it be an advisor which is kind
of cool so I'm looking forward to that
so I got a lot of stuff up doing and and
and being a father which I never was I
mean I literally was never there for my
kids I my poor older kids my two kids uh
they moved away so they didn't live in
the same state as I did so I hardly ever
saw them uh but me being a father now
and being able to spend the time with
them and and it's not too late it feels
really good um because I never wanted to
be that uh father that never took care
of their kids or didn't care about them
and I'm able to do that now and I'd be
honest with you I feel like an Uber
service I'm taking my kids to piano I'm
taking them the violin I'm taking them
to soccer I'm taking them to wrestling
practice my seven-year-old is a wrestler
a little girl she's she's actually
pretty good um you know I we a lot of
them have learning disabilities we take
them to speech therapy and it's just all
day all night but I love it because I
get to spend time with them you know
every once in a while doing appearance
to show my appreciation for the fans uh
but other than that I'm a father and I
absolutely love I'm a husband I love
that too I think you've been very lucky
Kurt if you don't mind me saying that
you've been able to pull it back in time
and and to have that you know because I
think as men we judge ourselves on I'm a
you know a good man and I'm doing the
right thing by the people around me and
I'm glad you got to make it right thank
you yeah you know what you look one last
question for
you you look like Triple H right now
I've heard that before I've heard that
before uh maybe give him a ring and get
me in into the uh into the center cuz
ironically uh I'm quite I'm friendly
with Logan Paul I'm good mates with
Logan so maybe we could sort that Feud
Out YouTube Feud actually while we're on
Logan I don't know if you've seen him
but he right now he's having one of the
fastest Rises arguably since you and
Brock and I wanted to know what you're
making of the YouTuber turned wrestler
you know what he's another kid that uh
has really you know at first I was like
yeah you know he's a YouTuber you know
he's just trying to get a Fame uh but
but he was producing he's winning fights
and then he goes to the WWE and he shows
his athleticism and it's like whoa this
kid has it why wasn't this kid why did
this kid start out with YouTube why
didn't this kid Excel you know be a pro
boxer when he was younger or or a pro
wrestler like this kid has the ability
to be those all those all the above and
uh watching him I literally impressed by
his skills and I'm really happy for him
he just won the US title I think that's
a great accomplishment for only
wrestling your eighth match uh I will
tell you this I won the Intercontinental
title wrestling my ninth match so I I
know the feeling wow but but you know he
he's on that he's he's on that uh level
with me and Brock I mean he really is
and uh I think if he Contin on and he
has more experience because he's not
quite experienced enough yet I think if
he gets more experience he's going to be
really really good and I think he'll end
up being world
champion well that's High Praise indeed
from the Olympic hero and I mean as you
say um he has an amateur background in
wrestling uh in his high school um and I
think that that does show in in in his
athleticism if you were to give him any
advice being that he is in that
trajectory of of similar to yourself
what would it
be um try not to spread yourself too
thin I know he's got a bunch of [__]
going on you know his prime drink and
wrestling I don't know if he's still
fighting or not he got the YouTube thing
I don't know if he's still doing that
but he seems to be all over the place
and that's really good as long as he has
a great management team but just you
know try to focus on one or two things
and do the best you can at those one or
two things I think that's one thing I
would say David Logan if you if you love
wrestling focus on it make it your first
love and make it first priority and do
what you got to do to become world
champion I agree I actually think he is
as good as he is as a boxer I think he's
even better as a wrestler and I dropped
them a message and I said you know these
Prime bottles you got to get up on that
turn bottle and do the Stone Cold Steve
Austin with the prime bottles when's
that coming um but my last question for
you k um and thanks again for your time
is how would you like to be
remembered um I I would love to be
remembered as a person that was
respectful to others um that uh I I
didn't have an ego that I was a very
humble individual that I was a great
father a great husband uh I want to be
remembered as one of the greatest of all
time in amateur and pro wrestling uh I
think I've been able to accomplish that
feat uh so uh you know you know what's
crazy you know uh I was told this last
week and and it's kind of rings true um
you know is anybody going to remember me
100 years from now I you know I I start
thinking about those things like what
what happens in 100 years what's going
to change and what people will be
remembered uh you absolutely were one of
the greatest of all time Kur not a doubt
in the minds of the people um I want to
thank you for all of the hours of
entertainment for this interview it's
made my day it honestly like I'm a huge
fan so thanks so much I really
appreciate it thank you so much I
appreciate me you having me on I had a
lot of fun today too talking about all
my much
appreciated it means the world Co thanks
a lot and you take care love to the
family see you all right take care my
friend
[Music]
byebye